tourville touristique et pourquoi pas
ville culturelle c'est ce que
souhaiteraient les candidats à la mairie
riche en expositions notamment au musée
des beaux-arts ou au château de tours la
ville eux semblent cependant manqué de
festival c'est en tout cas ce que
souligne guillaume la pac tête de liste
du modem on n'a pas réussi à maintenir
de grands festivals et on a aujourd'hui
un vrai problème de ce point de vue là
nous ce qu'on a inscrit dans notre
programme c'est la création d'un
festival de cinéma européen
parce que ça réaffirmera la vocation de
tourcom une ville européenne et que ça
permettra également de faire découvrir
les différents pays d'europe en
organisant un festival dans lequel
seront projetés des films venant des
différents états membres de la
communauté de son côté le maire ps
sortant jean germain propose d'amplifier
les activités culturelles existantes
avant de créer à nouveau pour lui il
s'agit donc d'abord de rénover les
bâtiments actuels ou la culture prend
forme mais aussi de rendre celle-ci
accessible à tous les budgets en six ans
on à reconstruire un théâtre entièrement
et une médiathèque et puis là on a
d'autres projets un centre d'art
contemporain la fondation devrait la
rénovation globale bibliothèque centrale
la réfection du musée des beaux-arts ça
c'est pour les investissements et puis
en ce qui concerne l'aspect de la vie de
tous les jours on veut créer un pass
culturel de façon à ce qu'on puisse
avoir selon les moyens de chacun la
possibilité d'assister à tout ce qui se
passe à tours pour vos dynamiser la
ville sur le plan culturel renaud
donnedieu de vabres candidat ump a quant
à lui en projet de transformer la
bibliothèque municipale en cité des arts
et des artistes et de créer un festival
des arts italien autre point de son
programme faire en sorte que tous les
tourangeaux puissent se rendre à des
manifestations et ce quelle que soit
leur situation familiale surtout les
lieux culturels il y aura une garderie
d'enfants ça veut dire que pour un
spectacle au grand théâtre au sens
dramatique pour l'activité artistique
ici un jeune ménage qui voudra à venir
le soir voir un spectacle où d'ailleurs
une manifestation sportive
trouvera sur place une halte garderie
pour ses enfants ça permettra qu'il n'y
ait pas tour à deux vitesses et ça
permettra pour les familles de pouvoir
vivre une vie agréable
création de festivals
amplification des événements existant
réhabilitation des lieux culturels
actuelle est mise en place de systèmes
pour ouvrir les arts à l'ensemble de la
population
quel que soit le candidat en 2008 la
culture s'annonce donc en chantier